>> Greg: HUNTER REFUSES TO
SHARE HIS FINANCES WITH THE BABY
MAMA WHO GAVE HIM LAP DANCES.
COURT DOCUMENTS REVEAL THE
SMARTEST MAN JOE KNOWS IS TRYING
TO WEASEL OUT OF SUPPORT
PAYMENTS OF LOVE CHILD WITH A
FORMER EXOTIC DANCER, KNOWN AS A
STRIPPER.
ALTHOUGH THE JUDGE KNOWS HE PAYS
WITH $1 BILL FOR FIRST HUNTER
DENIED THE KID WAS HIS UNTIL THE
COURT MATCHED HIS DNA WHICH THEY
SCRAPED OFF A CEILING AT A MOTE.
HUNTER REPORTEDLY IS TRYING TO
LOWER THE AMOUNT DUE TO A CHANGE
IN HIS FINANCIAL CIRCUMSTANCES.
AS WE ALL KNOW, INFLATION HAS
MADE A REALLY HARD TO AFFORD
CHILD SUPPORT AND CRACK COCAINE.
HE CLAIMS HE'S BROKE.
JUDGE RUDOLPH AND FARRIS SEEN
HERE WILL NOT MAKE RECORDS
PUBLIC AT HUNTER'S FIREARM CASE.
YOU RECALL THAT HUNTER FOSTER'S
GUN ENDED UP IN A TRASH CAN IN
2018 ON TO YOUR REALIZE IT WAS
DUMPED BY HIS BROTHER'S WIDOW
WHO HE WAS BANGING AT THE TIME.
WHO CAN'T RELATE TO THAT?
THE OBAMA APPOINTED JUDGE RULED
OUT THAT PRIVACY OUTWEIGHS
RELEASING THE RECORDS TO THE
PUBLIC.
PRIVACY?
IF THIS JUDGE CARES ABOUT
HUNTER'S PRIVACY, HE'D HOLD HIM
IN CONTEMPT UNTIL HE PUTS ON
SOME PANTS.
TALK ABOUT A MAN WHO'S SAVED
MORE DICK PICS THAN
RICHARD NIXON'S BIOGRAPHER.
YES, I'LL TAKE SOME APPLAUSE.
>> I GET IT.
>> THAT'S WHY YOU ARE NUMBER
ONE, SIR.
>> Greg: I WILL NOT BACK AWAY
FROM A [BLEEP] JOKE UNLESS IT'S
FROM A MAN NAMED
-- SHE'S TALKING ABOUT TAKING
RESPONSIBILITY.
THIS IS HIS KID.
THIS KID IS GOING GROW UP
KNOWING HIS DAD, HIS UNCLE IS
PRESIDENT!
I DON'T KNOW WHAT I JUST SAID.
>> YOU SKIPPED SOMETHING.
>> HIS DAD IS HIS UNCLE.
>> I THINK WE SHOULD JUST MOVE
ON.
I THINK IT'S ALSO GOING TO
SPECIALLY BE TOUGH BECAUSE THE
KID CAN JUST GO ON THE INTERNET
AND FIND OUT THAT HIS DAD ALSO
HAS ITS NOT ROCKETS THAT MAKE
$75,000 EACH.
HE JUST SHOOTS THE PAINT OUT OF
HIS NOSE AND BOOM, 75 GRAND.
MY IT'S NOT ROCKETS
MY 'S
DOESN'T HAVE ENOUGH CONNECTIONS
TO POWER.
THE LAST PERSON WHO CAN COMPLAIN
SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
>> Greg: I FEEL LIKE YOU HAVE
A STRONG...
JUST THE WAY YOU ARE LOOKING AT
ME I'M FRIGHTENED.
>> YEAH.
I REALLY WISH I HAD MY
SUNGLASSES RIGHT NOW.
>> AND WHATNOT.
>> WHATNOT.
I FEEL THE PAIN OF --
>> Greg: CHILD SUPPORT?
RIDICULOUS CHILD SUPPORT.
BUT YOU JUST GOT TO PAY THAT
[BLEEP], MAN.
HE'S GOT TO DO IT.
IT SUCKS.
WHEN YOU HAVE AS MANY CASH
AVENUES AS HE DOES, IT'S
PATHETIC.
IT'S NOT LIKE HE DOESN'T HAVE A
FEW FRIENDS IN CHINA THAT COULD
CUT HIM A CHECK.
>> YES!
HE WILL ENGAGE IN CORRUPTION FOR
ANYONE BUT HIS CHILD.
>> YEAH.
HE CAN GET MONEY FROM ANYWHERE.
IF HE CUT BACK TO JUST ONE
HOOKER A WEEK, HE CAN SUPPORT MY
KIDS ALSO.
>> Greg: THAT'S TRUE.
HE SPENDS SO MUCH MONEY ON SOME
OF THE BAD THINGS.
>> BUT ALSO WITH THE WHOLE RIGHT
TO LIFE THING, I THINK MEN,
JUST MOVE ON FROM IT.
>> Greg: WHAT IF THIS WAS A
TRUMP SON MAKING ART OUT OF HIS
SNOT, BANGING STRIPPERS,
KNOCKING THEM UP?
>> WE'D NEVER HEAR THE END OF
IT.
BUT THIS THING IS HE'S TRICKY.
"I CAN AFFORD CHILD SUPPORT" BUT
HE'S NOT VERY SMART.
IF HE HAS TO GO TO A COURT IN
THE SAY, I WANT TO GET MY CHILD
SUPPORT REDUCED BECAUSE OF MY
FINANCIAL SITUATIONS.
WHAT DOES A JUDGE SAY A QUESTION
MIKE SEE THOSE TAX RETURNS.
THAT'S WHERE THEY GET HIM.
HE'S GOING TO BE ON THE RECORD
FOR WHERE DOES ALL THAT MONEY
GO?
WHERE DOES IT ALL GO?
THEY GOT AL CAPONE ON TAX
EVASION BUT NOT ON KILLING HALF
THE PEOPLE IN CHICAGO.
>> Greg: ROB, IF YOUR DAD'S
HUNTER AND MOM IS A STRIPPER,
THIS KID IS GOING TO BE AN
EXTROVERT.
>> HE'S A LUCKY LUCKY LITTLE
KID.
AS YOU KNOW, I'M NOT A LICENSED
PSYCHOLOGIST IN THE STATE OF
NEW YORK.
>> Greg: BUT YOU DO LOOK LIKE
ONE.
>> I HAD A THERAPIST WHO LOOKS
JUST LIKE YOU.
>> OBVIOUSLY HE'S RECOVERING, WE
HOPE, A DRUG ADDICT.
INFLUENCE PEDDLER.
FORGETFUL COMPUTER OWNER.
WE KNOW THAT.
NOW HE'S A DEADBEAT DAD BUT HE'S
DOING ALL THIS STUFF TO GET
ATTENTION AND THE MEDIA AND
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" AND CNN,
THEY REFUSED TO GIVE IT TO HIM
EVEN THOUGH HE DESPERATELY
CRAVES IT.
THEY DON'T REALLY WANT TO COVER
THIS STORY.
HE'S GOING TO DO MORE AND MORE
CRAZY OUTLANDISH STUFF.
SOMEBODY IS GOING TO GET HURT.
THIS GUY WANTS TO BE ON THE
FRONT PAGE.
I SAY FOR THE SAKE OF ALL OF OUR
SAFETY HE SHOULD BE ON THE FRONT
PAGE.
>> Greg: WE'VE EXTENDED THE
INVITATION TO HUNTER TO BE PART
OF THE PANEL.
>> MAY BE OFFER HIM A CHECK.
>> Greg: EXACTLY BIT I'LL BUY
ONE OF HIS PAINTINGS.
>> HE'LL PUT A STRIPPER THROUGH
COLLEGE BUT NOT HIS CHILD.
>> Greg: EXACTLY.
>> THAT'S WHY TH